we've got two right triangles here and
let's say we also know that they both
have an angle whose measure is equal to
theta so angle a is congruent to angle d
what do we now know about these two
triangles
well for any right or any triangle if
you know two of the angles you're going
to know the third angle because the sum
of the angles of a triangle add up to
180 degrees so if you have two angles in
common that means you're going to have
three angles in common and if you have
three angles in common you are dealing
with similar triangles let me make that
a little bit clearer
so if this angle is theta this is 90
they all have to add up to 180 degrees
that means that this angle plus this
angle up here have to add up to 90.
we've already used up 90 right over here
so this angle angle a and angle b need
to be complements so this angle right
over here needs to be 90 minus theta
well we can use the same logic over here
we already used up 90 degrees over here
so we have a remaining 90 degrees
between theta and that angle so this
angle is going to be 90 degrees minus
theta 90 degrees minus theta you have
three congruent three corresponding
angles being congruent you are dealing
with similar triangles
now why is that interesting well we know
from geometry that the ratio of
corresponding sides of a similar
triangles are always going to be the
same so let's explore the corresponding
sides here
well the the the side that jumps out
when you're dealing with the right
triangles the most is always the
hypotenuse so this right over here is
the hypotenuse this hypotenuse is going
to correspond to this hypotenuse right
over here
i know we could write that down
this is the hypotenuse of this triangle
this is the hypotenuse this is the
hypotenuse of that triangle
now
this side right over here side bc what
side does that correspond to
well if you look at this triangle you
can kind of view it as the side that is
opposite this angle theta so it's
opposite if you go across the triangle
you get there so let's go opposite angle
d if you go opposite angle a you get to
bc opposite angle d you get to ef
you get e f so it corresponds to this
side right over here
and then finally side ac is the one
remaining one we could view it as well
there's two sides that make up this
angle a one of them is a hypotenuse we
could call this maybe the adjacent side
to it and so d corresponds to a and so
this would be the side that corresponds
now the whole reason i did that is to
leverage that corresponding sides the
ratio between corresponding sides of
similar triangles is always going to be
the same
so for example the ratio between bc and
the hypotenuse ba so let me write that
down
bc
over
ba
b
a
is going to be equal to
e f over
e d
e f
e f the length of segment ef
over the length of segment e d
over the length of segment
e d
or we could also write
that the length of segment ac
so ac
over the hypotenuse over this triangle's
hypotenuse over a
b
is equal to
df over d e once again
this green side over the orange side
these are similar triangles they're
corresponding to each other so this is
equal to
this is equal to d
f
over
d e
over
d e
or we could also say we could keep going
but i'll just do another one or we could
say that the ratio of this side right
over this blue side to the green side
so of this triangle
bc
the length of bc over ca
over c a
is going to be the same as the blue the
ratio between these two corresponding
sides the blue over the green e f
e
f
over d f
over
df and we got all of this from the fact
that these are similar triangles so this
is true for all similar triangles or
this is true for any right triangle that
has an angle theta it's going then those
two triangles are going to be similar
and all of these ratios are going to be
the same well maybe we can give names to
these ratios relative to the angle theta
so from angle theta's point of view
from theta's point of view i'll write
theta right over here or we can just
remember that what are these what is the
ratio of these two sides well from
theta's point of view
that blue side is the opposite side it's
opposite it's on the opposite side of
the right triangle
and then the orange side we've already
labeled the hypotenuse so from theta's
point of view this is the opposite side
over the hypotenuse
and i keep stating from theta's point of
view because that wouldn't be the case
for this other angle for angle b from
angle b's point of view this is the
adjacent side over the hypotenuse and
we'll think about that relationship
later on but let's just think of it from
theta's point of view right over here so
from theta's point of view what is this
well theta's right over here
clearly
a b and d e a b and d e are still the
hypotenuses hypotenuse i don't know how
to say that in plural again
and what is ac or and what what is ac
and what are df well these are adjacent
to it they're one of the sides two sides
that make up this angle that is not the
hypotenuse so this we can view as the
ratio and either of these triangles
between the adjacent side
so this is relative once again this is
opposite angle b but we're only thinking
about angle a right here or angle the
angle that measures theta or angle d
right over here relative to angle a ac
is adjacent relative to angle d df
is adjacent so this ratio right over
here is the adjacent
over the hypotenuse and it's going to be
the same relative for any right triangle
that has an angle theta in it and then
finally this over here this is going to
be the opposite side once again this was
the opposite side over here this ratio
for either right triangle is going to be
the opposite side
over the adjacent side over
the adjacent side
and i really want to stress the
importance we're going to do many many
more examples of this to make this very
concrete but for any right triangle that
has an angle theta the ratio between its
opposite side and its hypotenuse is
going to be the same
that comes out of similar triangles
we've just explored that the ratio
between the adjacent side to that angle
that is theta and the hypotenuse is
going to be the same for any
any of these triangles as long as it has
that angle theta in it and the ratio
relative to the angle theta between the
opposite side and the adjacent side
between the blue side and the green side
is always going to be the same these are
similar triangles so given that
mathematicians decide to give these
things names relative to the angle theta
this ratio is always going to be the
same so they call this the opposite of
our hypotenuse they call this the sine
of the angle theta
so this is
the sine let me do this in a new
and a new color
this is by definition
and we're going to extend this
definition in the future this is sine
of theta
this right over here by definition is
the cosine
of theta
and this right over here by definition
is
the
tangent
that by definition is the tangent of
theta and a mnemonic that will help you
remember this and these really are just
definitions people realize wow by
similar triangles for any angle theta
this ratio is always going to be the
same for for because of similar
triangles for any angle theta this ratio
is always going to be same this ratio is
always going to be same so let's make
these definitions and to help us
remember it there's the mnemonic
sohcahtoa so i'll write like this so
so
so is sine is opposite over hypotenuse k
cosine
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse and
then finally tangent
tangent
is opposite over adjacent tangent is
opposite
opposite
over
opposite over adjacent so katoa and in
future videos we'll actually apply
these really these definitions these for
these trigonometric functions